tod et wolf souterrain est un retour aux
sources pour vous parce que ça se
déroule dans une mine à val d'or où vous
avez grandi justement d'en face que
c'est un film que vous portez en vous de
plus tôt jours pratiquement depuis que
je suis à l'université
quand tyler ton cinéma un moment donné
j'étais en visite à val d'or avec chez
mon père qui m'a emmené dans une mine
pendant tout un col travail puis j'ai
fait au monde il va falloir que je fasse
un film dans les mines réjouies et avec
mais aujourd'hui alors qu'on se donne
beaucoup de beau jeu sous terre
à ma grande surprise vous avez par
l'université de votre jeunesse c'est en
écoutant la grenouille et la baleine
adolescente que vous avez en quelque
sorte d'estrade cinéma plus tard parce
que vous aimez les films qui font
pleurer c'est la grenouille et la
baleine est vraiment au plus haut point
quand j'étais jeune quand j'étais jeune
je me suis que ça me parlait ce fils
hommes et toutes les femmes un peu
quitte ici que de mettre des émotions
qui met adolescente j'écoutais beaucoup
de films des drames
c'est vraiment le trip de faire comme
mon dieu on fait vivre des émotions
aussi fortes on me fait pleurer puis
c'est ça arrivait des fois moi je suis
enfin unique restée dans ma chambre
enfermé puis je m'étais vhs après vhs
puis j'écoutais les scènes qui faisait
pleurer je pleurais je pleurais tout la
souris puis je me dis c'est
extraordinaire de pouvoir qui reste chez
quelqu'un fait quand j'étais jeune je
voulais faire il me faisait pleurer
aujourd'hui je veux faire des films qui
font vivre des émotions des émotions
fortes
d'où schengen vivre en 2018 des émotions
ouais ouais autant à l'écriture au
tournage que toute sa vie après à
laquelle je m'attendais pas du tout
quand j'ai reçu l'appel pour nous dire
qu'on représentait le canada aux oscars
je suis tombé de ma chaise je t'ai pas
prêts du tout on dit souvent qu'un grand
artiste fait une grande oeuvre puis il
se répète par la suite
est-ce que parfois vous avez un peu
l'impression que c'est votre coche je
pense à chiens de garde une magnifique
scène se rallie à eux deux personnages
qui se passe c'est vrai c'est la
réconciliation et d'un souterrain sans
doute eu des files indiennes et dans ce
corps est la même mais me sens et break
qui tous si belles et célèbres herman
loin d'être un ouais ouais
est ce que vous étiez consciente cela
n'ôte vois je l'avais j'avais jamais vu
ça mais des fois j'ai cru d'un simple je
me dis que j'écris cette sangle jeu
[Musique]
croisé puis geneviève puis on choisit de
avant ça m'arrive
il ya des phrases qui reviennent aussi
mais je m'en fais pas exposé au froid
que je tapais la montée ça fait une
bonne dizaine d'années que vous êtes
réalisatrice et vous avez déjà pendant
l'entrevue des aléas financiers du
métier comment vous vivez ça moi dans
mon cas je m'étais dit je veux faire mes
films
donc je vais faire tout ce qu'il faut
pour j'ai vécu à ses petites mains on va
dire pendant plusieurs années en disant
faut que je garde les sous pour pouvoir
faire c'était mon objectif
donc mais c'est sûr que si j'avais une
famille si j'avais eu des groupements
faire peut-être que je serais même pas
là aujourd'hui parce que il aurait fallu
que je fasse des sacrifices mais là j'ai
réussi à faire en sorte que j'ai
toujours écrit des films sans arrêt
quelque chose avec quoi je pense juste
sur un but chanceux c'est que j'arrive à
écrire rapidement puis même astuce c'est
quand même une vingtaine de versions
j'écris pour une version pc terminé 20
versions à au moins au moins moi je
crois beaucoup à la réécriture je crois
beaucoup que ta première idée si jamais
la bonne puisque tu peux toujours avoir
quelque chose de plus intéressant
une façon plus intéressante de dire une
façon plus intéressant de montrer d'eux
donc moi je crois beaucoup à la
réécriture mais j'écris je peux écrire
un scénario en quelques mois puis au
travers de ce fait une vingtaine de
versions dès le départ les non fans
l'adorent
j'adore celle du travail c'est du
travail puis il faut être capable de
jeter des affaires mme dessin ekstrom
extraordinaire d'après moi que j'ai vu
que j'ai écrite que je rêvais tournée
que j'ai jamais tourné puisque je vais
jamais tourné parce que c'est ce qui est
mieux pour le film donc ça pour être
capable de valider mais parlant d'argent
la sodec viens de vous donner 2 5
millions de dollars pour drague votre
troisième long métrage
vous avez terminé l'écriture peut-être
la 20e révisions je sais pouvoir dire
aux bandes
c'est sur l'univers des drag queens
notamment allez-vous appli michel
tremblay pour lui pose des questions sur
aux anneaux et j'ai vu aux anneaux en
plus dernièrement ils ont monté à
montréal et je serai toujours enchantés
de parler avec monsieur trably de tous
est derrière de draquila tout le reste
sophie dupuis merci beaucoup et on me
dit le mot de cambronne pour le gala
québec cinéma 13 nominations
oui il faut pas répondre à ça s'ils
étaient seuls choisi vous à vernon b